hey
hi it's january 3rd um i actually
haven't even posted a video in 2008 yet
and i'm going to start trying to do the
meet today's a little more frequently
um it's raining
it's my umbrella's going the opposite
direction
um
basically
yeah it's really cold really really cold
i am in san francisco
my flight's delayed i was actually
supposed to have already left the city
but
uh yeah delta they're kind enough to
actually give you a call
and email you if your flight's too late
so
thankfully i'd have to see the airport
for hours
heading to la
a little bit better because this is
ridiculous look are you doing any good
no you're not getting
i'm started
to walk this way i just changed my mind
i'm changing my direction because
i'm getting
rained on and
my umbrella is getting mad at me and
it's
stuff inside out
oh goodness oh boy
yeah okay all right i think that i'm
gonna just stop this video and
concentrate
a little
bit
harder on walking
so i'm gonna do happy new year's
everybody love you bye